per session we talked about a little bit
about so there's arguments saying that
some people actually employ violence's
means draw attention intro international
pressure to help solve the issue so the
argument goes the head RA not employing
von z online they actually flow maybe in
UK people pay attention to that by nine
fish around the parts of world nobody
will care and their grievance would
never heard when never be heard and the
problem when every thought so how would
you respond to that already I think this
is a really good question is a very very
hard one to answer honestly because this
is one of the most this is a very
dangerous answer if you answer yes I
think I think however that there why
make two points I'd say first of all
there are ways actually and the civil
rights movement here in a way was an
example of how we okay the work elements
of violence around that actually was
basically a peaceful movement gandy a
peaceful movement you don't need to be
violent but you do need to draw
attention but violence isn't the only
way of drawing attention I think
secondly this was the debate i really
had with the IRA and shouldn't fain in
the last two years before i left office
my argument to them was and this has
gained importance of the dialogue we had
amines maybe just worth saying this that
when i first met Gerry Adams and Martin
beginners i mean i was obviously a huge
thing for me to meet them and so on and
i remember there's a major question as
to whether i would shake hands with them
or not and i met them and i did shake
answer them right there later that day i
went to visit a unionist area and the
whole of what looked to be very
respectable kind of granny's sort of
hanging around doing the shopping
everything as I went into this shopping
precinct and they suddenly morphed into
the screaming shouting bully returnees
waiting rubber gloves at me and I'm
sorry I was so I got very low Moses
esoteric completely I couldn't get the
rubber gloves thing at all you know I
kind of thought maybe they've been doing
the washing up and just come out quickly
or something and then suffice it to be
notice because you're shaking hands with
Gerry Adams this is you should have been
wearing rubber gloves cuz he was such an
evil person you have something shaking
hands of them so there was this anyway
there's this so it gets into Northern
Ireland and this is this whole business
though about meeting them and being able
to talk to them allowed me over time to
establish the relationship where we
started to have a real debate and I was
saved them I understand why you may
think that your violence brought this
issue to people's attention but believe
me we are now at this stage where your
violence is the thing that stops us
being resolved so you know it's
interesting at both levels so I know
it's difficult to answer your question
yes you have to bring it to people's
attention maybe violence isn't the only
way you can do it however but the second
thing is the acts of engagement if it
can establish a relationship means that
suddenly you the power of persuasion is
at least on the table and I think in the
end what Gerry Adams a shadow and Marta
McGinnis I think I don't think they
needed huge convincing might be I think
they were coming to their own conclusion
finally what clinched the Northern
Ireland deal was the I our age is saying
ok work we're going away you know we're
not surrendering we're just disappearing
and actually that was then the moment
when unionism was faced with its moment
of truth because then the entire
justification for
the refusal was then removed and that
was the moment of which in Paisley I
mean had to decide until fairy decided
the right way at to decide whether
really the problem was violence or
really the problem was they weren't at
the same tribe